the Joe Rogan experience this idea that
you can deep platform people and somehow
know that weakens the position that you
don't agree with it's the opposite the
opposite happens you pump up the only
hope that they have of getting their
side of the story out there their side
of the story is going to be represented
by Trump and Trump supporters and I
don't know what the president can or
can't do to sort of enforce some sort of
I mean we obviously have a new situation
when it comes to communication in this
country with social media and tech
companies yes it's very new and it's
really it's it's only the last couple of
decades it's even been a thing and now
it's one of the biggest things I'm going
to income in terms of discourse and how
people communicate and how people form
opinions about things that's a
tremendous influence on our culture yeah
and the fact that this isn't protected
by the First Amendment we have a very
strange new force in our country when it
comes to discourse and I think laws need
to be formed that we need to have some
sort of parameters that you mean there's
laws on virtually everything and
virtually everything that has massive
influence over the way it affects our
country and that's one where there isn't
really there's no independent companies
and there they're not there they can do
whatever they want yeah essentially yeah
I mean no it's it's limitless I think I
agree with you I think this is I agree
with you both with regards to the tech
companies but also this bigger kind of
culture war that's happened here in our
country this canceled culture that
exists that I think I mean it does it
threatens the kind of of freedom of
speech and and discourse and I think
we've celebrated in this country for so
long where this is the country yeah
where you can stand up and say what you
believe no matter how terrible I may
think it is or how strongly I may
disagree with it you know people like us
are willing to lay our life down for
your right to do that I think that's
that's what is at risk here with this
this culture this this cancel culture
it's having such a chilling effect where
people are maybe afraid to say something
that may be seen as controversial to
some because they will get cancelled and
in summer and in some cases you've seen
how people's is
if you're a public figure whole career
can be just like gone finished canceled
cultures real simple everyone now has a
rock and there's a big window someone
throws a rock at that window and you're
like well [ __ ] throw a my rock - and
that's what happens people just whether
or not they have a strong opinion of
something or not they just decide that's
the spot we're throwing the rocks right
and they just chucked the rocks and then
they feel like they have some sort of a
part you know if a politician gets taken
down they're like look I helped look at
my Twitter feed my Twitter feeds filled
with calling that guy pieces I was the
first one yeah the first one that did it
I think that that um you know you
mentioned was it happen in the debate
Kamala Harris was shoot she'd like
launched a petition or publicly was
calling for Twitter to delete president
Trump's account yeah and she really
really made a big deal out of this did a
whole media tour like all this is called
out Elizabeth Warren all this stuff I
was asked about it by a reporter shortly
after she had made this announcement I
did not even heard of it like what do
you think about Kamala Harris calling on
Twitter - canceled Trump's Twitter
account said well you know I disagree
with not everything a lot of what Trump
says but freedom of speech freedom of
speech so no I completely disagree with
her and the response from her campaign
spokesperson no kidding
tulsi gabbard echoes fox news talking
points freedom of fox news is saying oh
well what about freedom of speech by the
way Richard Spencer loves her but that's
like this is where we're at like just
saying hey freedom of speech you're the
president with you're the president
United States or you're the guy sweeping
the floor in the White House I will
stand up and fight for your freedom of
speech I may disagree and I may disagree
publicly and strongly but we've got it
we've got to draw the line here for
freedom of speech and being able to have
this dialogue in discourse where we can
and I think that we should debate
strongly and maybe passionately about
some of these issues not seeing that as
a bad thing
that's been the strength of our country
it'll be interesting you know from a
free market perspective if at some point
somebody comes out with a social media
platform that is really truly
free speech done that rolls theirs
thinks pocket runaround how
gasps yeah it'll just be yeah and but
people have told me Tech friends of mine
that say they say that immediately turns
into what is it for Shan an H and it
just immediately goes into the gutter
it's an open sewer I mean it's just like
have you ever seen those pipes that
pumps sewage into the ocean I mean and
it's not the fault of the social media
company so the companies like gab
they're committed to free speech and
what they're trying to do is let it just
let it all work itself out and abide by
the Constitution don't Doc's anybody
don't give up anybody's address right
and threaten anybody or do any harm and
just talk crazy and do it anonymously
and that's what a lot of people are
doing and but it's it's very difficult
for even the people that felt like they
were deep platformed or their voice
wasn't being able to be heard they don't
want to join in to this crazy [ __ ]
because because of 4chan all this
savages just trying to post pictures of
their dinner so nuts I mean look I mean
even posting pictures of your dinner I
mean you get you do that on Instagram
and if it's a dead deer or something
like that your your risk of getting your
picture taken down it's the amount of
power that's being exhibited by these
social media companies again no one
anticipated this what could be done what
do you think could be done like say you
you get you become president what would
you do so I think there's there's two
things here that we've talked about the
freedom of speech the control over
information I think part and parcel to
that that we didn't really talk much
about is how much of our private
information these tech companies have
and what they're doing with it
maybe without us even knowing about how
that's that's helping to drive up their
profits I think it's it's both of those
components you got to be concerned about
think number one is we look at our
antitrust laws that exist in this
country for the protection of the
consumer against any giant monopolies
from coming in and be in a position to
abuse their power and apply those laws
to these tech giants I think the fact
that Facebook owns obviously Facebook
Instagram and whatsapp
I don't think that I think that is the
definition of a monopoly across
platforms that many of us use because
there isn't really a legitimate
alternative option available to us so I
think that's that the first thing and
looking at breaking up these these
monopolies I think Facebook's co-founder
it's a Chris Hayes I think is his name I
think he wrote I think very compelling
argument against Facebook monopoly
saying they have gotten way too powerful
they should not have been able to buy
these other companies and the second
thing is Congress actually digging down
and passing laws that provide actual
oversight and a level of accountability
to ensure that our freedom of speech and
our freedom to access information is not
impeded by these tech giants whether
it's for their own profits or to pursue
their own political interests they face
they face there's people inside of
Twitter that are like Jack Dorsey
believes and at least according to what
he's told me that Twitter should be like
a town hall where everyone should be
able to have access but he faces
resistance that inside the actual
company that he's a CEO of there's so
many people that don't think that that's
the way it should be and they think that
they have a political or a social
obligation to limit certain voices
because those voices radicalize young
people like what do you say to those
people I mean with without knowing
examples of what they're citing here's
the thing is is what they may view is
radicalizing young people because of the
ideology that they as individuals may
hold on to may be seen in the opposite
way by people who hold a different
political ideology you know I think this
is something that that that we're seeing
happening offline as well you know
whether it's in in college campuses or
in other places where both sides view
the other side as indoctrinating young
people are indoctrinating people with
their ideology
[Applause]